à 87 ans la juge de la cour suprême ruth
bader ginsburg s'est éteinte à la suite
d'une longue maladie
celle qui est connue à travers les états
unis comme une icône de la cause
féministe se retrouve au coeur de la
campagne américaine bien malgré elle
pour le camp républicain
pas question d'attendre l'ancienne
magistrate doit être remplacé au plus
vite
nous entendons déjà des affirmations
erronées selon lesquelles il n'y a pas
suffisamment de temps pour examiner et
confirmé un candidat nous pouvons
dissiper ce mythe en 30 secondes
à ce jour il reste quarante trois jours
avant le 3 novembre et ce en quatre
jours avant la fin de ce congrès en 2016
mitch mcconnell avait pourtant bloqué le
vote sur la nomination par les
démocrates d'un juge à la cour suprême
arguments qu'il était inapproprié de le
faire en année électorale
donald trump a annoncé qu'il nommera en
fin de semaine une nouvelle juge
deux femmes sont en lice emiko nibards
est une fervente anti-ivg de 48 ans et
barbara l'agoa une magistrate
latino-américaine de 52 ans
la décision finale appartient cependant
au sénat sur 100 sièges 53 sont détenus
par les républicains deux d'entre eux
ont déjà annoncé leur refus d'élire une
nouvelle juge avant le résultat de la
présidentielle et deux autres sont
indécis le sujet inquiète fortement le
camp démocrate qui craint qu'une cour
conservatrice efface le droit à liv et g
et protège davantage la peine de mort
comme l'a expliqué tschopp chômeurs le
chef des démocrates au sénat
la dernière volonté de ruth bader
ginsburg et et qu'elles ne soient pas
remplacés avant les élections
présidentielles elle a dit mon plus
fervents souhait est que je ne sois pas
remplacés jusqu'à ce qu'un nouveau
président soit installé nous croyons en
cela le peuple américain aussi
aujourd'hui un sondage reuters a révélé
que 62% des américains étaient d'accord
avec elle s'est levée que cela signifie
que les démocrates les républicains les
indépendants conviennent tous que c'est
juste et qu'il faut respecter le dernier
souhait de rose bader ginsburg qui
souhaite ne pas être remplacé avant que
le nouveau président soit installé le
candidat démocrate à la maison blanche
joe biden à lui
si réagi aux souhaits de trump
d'accélérer le processus il dénonce une
politique brutale de la part du
président les peuples de cette nation
sont en train de choisir leur avenir
maintenant forcé cette nomination en
passant par le sénat est juste un
exercice de pouvoir politique brutale à
moins de deux mois des élections
l'enjeu de cette nomination accapare
désormais toute la campagne